[Musik]
maradona ein gebet auf hebräisch in
israel zum 75 jahrestag der befreiung
von auschwitz bekennt sich der
bundespräsident zum kampf gegen
antisemitismus und zu deutscher schuld
bundesweite razzien gegen
rechtsextremisten der innenminister hat
die neonazi gruppe combat tae jin
verboten und viele kritiker fragen warum
erst jetzt
20 millionen chinesen unter quarantäne
die behörden regeln mehrere großstädte
ab in ganz china wächst die angst vor
dem corona virus
die nachrichten nicht da das heute mit
christian sievers mit herrn guten abend
in allen wir haben für sie die
nachrichten dieses donnerstages
gebündelt und kristin otto steuert den
sport bei auch heute sehr gern genannt
die weltgemeinschaft gedenkt heute der
befreiung des kz auschwitz vor 75 jahren
zu der zeremonie in israels holocaust
gedenkstätte jad vaschem sind rund 50
staats und regierungschefs gekommen zum
ersten mal spricht dort auch ein
deutscher bundespräsident und frank
walter steinmeier gibt eine feste zusage
die flamme von jad vaschem erlischt
nicht und unsere deutsche verantwortung
vergeht nicht mit blick auf deutschland
heute sagt steinmeier
ich wünschte sagen zu können wir
deutsche haben für immer aus der
geschichte gelernt aber ich kann das
nicht sagen wenn hass und hetze sich
ausbreiten
deshalb darf es keinen schlussstrich
unter das erinnern geben und erneuert
ein versprechen wir bekämpfen den
antisemitismus wir schützen jüdisches
leben über diesen besonderen tag aus
jerusalem nicola albrecht die holocaust
gedenkstätte jad vaschem
die welt ist heute hierher bekommen zum
größten staatsereignis seit der gründung
israels 1948 dass frank walter
steinmeier als erster bundespräsident
hier eine rede halten darf wertet er
selbst als zeichen der versöhnung
aus respekt vor den überlebenden im
publikum spricht er englisch nicht
deutsch nicht die sprache der täter
ebenfalls laut liberation heraus
schweizer think before you as president
of germany eine stunt hier laden rudi
historical burden of great schirmherr
ist der israelische präsident rufen
rivlin in seiner eröffnungsrede fordert
er vor allem ein weltweites eintreten
gegen antisemitismus
die schirme antisemitismus ist eine
chronische krankheit sie kommt von
rechts von links sie hat im laufe der
geschichte verschiedene formen
angenommen
aber er ist da der antisemitismus daran
hat sich nichts geändert
spannungen gab es im vorfeld der
gedenkveranstaltung polens präsident
dürfte keine rede halten
sein platz blieb heute leer polen und
russland stritten sich um die richtige
interpretation der geschichte in einer
feierlichen anrührenden zeremonie sind
es schließlich der amerikanische
vizepräsident pence marke putin und
prinz charles die als vertreter der
alliierten sprechen sie alle setzen ein
klares gemeinsames signal dass es keinen
schlussstrich geben kann geben darf
steinmeier spricht erst nach ihnen
er kennt sich nicht nur zur
verantwortung für die ermordung von
sechs millionen juden durch das deutsche
nazi-regime
er findet auch klare worte für die
gegenwart wurden einige
holocaust-überlebende die gerne an
diesem tag nach japan gekommen wären
kritisierten dass es für sie keinen
platz in der zeremonie
als einziger überlebender nur er
sprechen durfte rabbi ihre das
bekenntnis der versammelten staatsführer
zum kampf gegen antisemitismus für ihn
ein versprechen und eine pflicht der
gesamten menschheit
historisches in yad vashem heute.de hat
die gesamte rede des bundespräsidenten
zum anschauen wie erwähnt auf englisch
und zum nachlesen auf deutsch direkt
darunter in deutschland geht die
bundesregierung weiter gegen die
rechtsextreme szene vor das
innenministerium hat jetzt die
gewaltbereite neonazi gruppe kombat
eltern verboten
sie sei mit dem nationalsozialismus
wesensverwandt und verstöße gegen gegen
die verfassung
bei razzien in mehreren bundesländern
wurde nach weiteren beweismaterial
gesucht kritiker sagen das verbot sei
richtig komme aber viel zu spät thomas
reichert die polizei kommt früh morgens
um 6 über 200 beamte durchsuchen in
sechs bundesländern die wohnungen
führender vereins mitglieder der
rechtsextremen gruppe combat team
beschlagnahmen laptops ten es musik und
devotionalien sowie waffen vom
innenminister dazu nur eine schriftliche
begründung für das verbot kombat in
deutschland hat die menschenverachtende
gesinnung mit der rechtsextremistische
und antisemitische hetze in unserer
gesellschaft hineingetragen combat team
geht als gewaltbereite neonazi gruppe
die sich über rechtsextreme musik
finanziert und verantwortlich sein soll
für drohbriefen flüchtlingsunterkünfte
moscheen und parteibüros sie soll
verbindungen pflegen zum platte
internets das bereits 2000 verboten
wurde das verbot für combat ihn dagegen
kann erst jetzt wo das schon vom halben
jahr angekündigt und die folge davon ist
natürlich dass man nicht mal mehr bei
dem dümmsten nazi irgendetwas finden
wird also zusammengefasst entscheidung
richtig viel zu spät die forderungen
nach einem verbot wurden besonders nach
dem mord am kasseler
regierungspräsidenten weiter lübke laut
der mutmaßliche täter soll kontakt
gehabt haben zur kompetenten mitgliedern
und stefan er unterstützte offenbar auch
die afd
wir sehen verquickungen die da sind
zwischen diesen rechten terror
netzwerken bis hin
ins parlament rhein zur afg und der
staat muss einfach handeln
ich glaube viel zu lange wurde auch im
innenministerium an anderen stellen
weggeguckt die durchsuchungen richteten
sich gegen die anführer der gruppe die
sich als eine art geheimbund sei welche
verbindungen sie pflegte müssen die
ermittler nun erst noch herausfinden und
dieser hinweis noch eine ausführliche
film doku über kombat ihn und die
neonazi-szene können sie in der zdf
mediathek sie was die behörden in china
jetzt tun hat es noch nie gegeben ganze
millionenstädte werden komplett
abgeriegelt alles um die ausbreitung des
neuartigen corona virus zu verhindern
flüge züge fähren busse alles steht
still
allein hin wo hahn sind elf millionen
menschen betroffen dort wo die krankheit
ende dezember erstmals aufgetreten ist
mittlerweile gibt es insgesamt mehr als
600 infizierte 18 sind bislang gestorben
axel conrad
hier kommt ab jetzt keiner mehr rein der
bahnhof von uran wird abgeriegelt
niemand soll die stadt verlassen nicht
mit dem zug dem flugzeug dem schiff und
nicht mit dem auto die sonst so emsige
millionen stadt wie ausgestorben
antragen nur in den apotheken das tragen
der atemmasken ist jetzt pflicht
dieses flugzeug hat johann noch vor der
quarantäne zu einem inlandsflug
verlassen
ein trupp ärztin schutzanzügen misst die
körpertemperatur aller reisenden
passagiere mit erhöhter temperatur
werden umgehend in die quarantäne
station gebracht die ist nur 30 meter
weg kein grund zur beunruhigung also
auch deutschland fühlt sich bestens
gewappnet archiv aufnahmen der sonde
isolierstation in frankfurt sieben
solcher zentren für den solchen notfall
gibt es bundesweit
wir sind gut vorbereitet unsere teams
können an den flughafen direkt fahren
wir können den passagier dann in unserem
sonder isolier fahrzeug in die
universitätsklinik fahren dort ist die
möglichkeit über eine schnelle
labordiagnostik festzustellen ob der
passagier etwas hat was in diese
richtung geht oder nicht und wir können
dann auch alle kontakt passagiere
erfassen innerhalb kürzester zeit in
peking proben sie am morgen noch für das
chinesische neujahrsfest den zwei tagen
doch der auftritt fällt wohl flach alle
großveranstaltungen wurden heute
abgesagt es herrscht angst das virus
könnte sich dort massenhaft verbreiten
unser china korrespondent ulf röller war
bis vor anderthalb tage noch in wulff
guten abend wie können sie die situation
dort jetzt beschreiben
als wir da waren herrschte noch so was
wie alltagsleben die menschen waren auf
der straße einige trugen schutzmasken
viele waren am bahnhof und sind einfach
weggefahren aus der stadt zu ihren
verwandten es ist ja quasi jetzt das
chinesische neujahrsfest was in
deutschland silvester ist sie gingen auf
den märkten einkaufen es war also eine
ganz normale stimmung wir haben jetzt
gerade vor zwei stunden mit unseren
kontakt info an geredet und er sagt eine
völlig andere situation diese
gigantische elf millionen stadt gleicht
doch fast einer geisterstadt keiner ist
mehr auf der straße die wenigen dient
man noch an trifft haben eben jetzt alle
schutzmasken diese doch sehr drastische
maßnahme der chinesischen regierung die
stadt abzuwickeln hat den leuten angst
gemacht und sie bleiben zu hause und sie
fürchten sich eben zu infizieren
dann gucken wir uns nochmal auf das
große
ist das jetzt neue offenheit in china im
umgang mit so einer krankheit oder steht
zu befürchten dass alles viel schlimmer
ist als wir bisher erfahren
also ich glaube dass die chinesische
regierung und auch der chinesische
präsident haben sich ja zu der krankheit
geäußert wirklich damit rechnen dass es
sehr dramatisch ist die experten sagen
die krankenzahlen wäre noch hoch gehen
auch die zahlen derjenigen die an der
krankheit sterben und was ich persönlich
frage woran ist eben diese gigantische
stadt von 11 millionen größer als london
new york und ich frage mich eben wie man
eine solche stadt wirklich abregeln will
das ist eigentlich nicht möglich und
damit ist es sehr sehr schwer diesen
virus einzudämmen
live aus peking heute abend ulf röller
herzlichen dank und damit zu unserem
nächsten thema ist gehe um eine frage
des überlebens so war bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel heute auf dem
weltwirtschaftsforum in davos für mehr
klimaschutz die welt müsse zusammen
handeln auch wenn nicht mehr alle dabei
sein sagte sie mit blick auf den
us-präsidenten
unterstützung bekam merkel dafür von
klimaschutz aktivisten aus davos stefan
leifert es gibt nicht viele die schon so
oft in diesem ort waren wie die die
heute kam zum zwölften mal spricht
angela merkel vor der weltwirtschafts
elite in davos ihre rede durchzogen von
der klimafrage und der tiefen kluft
zwischen den lagern die
unversöhnlichkeit und die
sprachlosigkeit die zum teil herrscht
zwischen denen die das den klimawandel
leugnen und denen die ihn sehen und
dafür kämpfen dass wir ihn bewältigen
die macht mir sorge und die muss
überwunden werden sprechen hier viele
menschen miteinander die selten
miteinander sprechen aber sprechen nicht
ausreichend viele menschen dass das
weltwirtschaftsforum fast zum weltklima
forum wurde ist auch ihnen geschuldet
die jungen aktivisten haben die sonst so
gediegene konferenz mächtig aufgemischt
dennoch bei ihnen dominiert auch nach
drei tagen da wo ist die skepsis der
green deal als idee es glaube ich gar
nicht schlecht
die frage ist ob der green deal
erschafft von einer vision die sich sehr
weit in der zukunft abspielt hinzu etwas
zu kommen was den heutigen ansprüchen
gerecht werden kann
es geht eben nicht und 2050 klimaneutral
werden sondern es geht darum heute hier
und jetzt einen weg einzuschlagen der
uns irgendwann mal dahin führen kann
zumindest rhetorisch stellt sich die
kanzlerin heute auf die seite der jungen
klimaaktivisten dass angela merkel hier
zwei tage nach donald trump redet ist
ein zufall des kalenders kein zufall ist
dass ihre rede hierzu widerrede wird die
kanzlerin macht sich zur anwältin aller
die die klimafrage für die
schicksalsfrage unserer zeit halten sagt
stefan leifert in davos morde
vergewaltigungen und niedergebrannte
dörfer mehr als 700.000 menschen
angehörige der muslimischen minderheit
der rohingya sind bereits aus myanmar
geflohen
der internationale gerichtshof in den
haag hat das land jetzt zum sofortigen
schutz der rohingya aufgefordert myanmar
müsse alles in seiner macht stehende tun
um einen völkermord zu verhindern
laut einem uno-bericht haben soldaten
aus myanmar über jahre hinweg tausende
rohingya ermordet regierungschef in st
er weist völkermord vorwürfe zurück und
spricht von einzelfällen in deutschland
heute früh ein unglück mit einem
schulbus in thüringen 28 jährige kinder
kamen dabei ums leben 20 weitere kinder
wurden verletzt
nördlich von eisenach am ortsrand von
berka vor dem heilig war der bus
unterwegs zur schule offenbar rutschte
er auf spiegelglattem kopfsteinpflaster
rückwärts einen hang hinunter und
überschlug sich dabei beate türen
berichtet eine glatte fahrbahn in einer
senke war wohl der grund warum der
schulbus hier kurz nach einer kurve ins
rutschen kam
besonders bitter die nebenstraße wird
aus sicherheitsgründen benutzt damit die
kinder im ort selbst auf dem weg zur
schule keine straße überqueren müssen
im bus saßen 22 grundschüler wenn zwei
kinder ums leben kommen
dann bleibt die welt im moment stehen
ein ganzer ort stehe unter schock sagt
auch thüringens innenminister die
psychologische betreuung der betroffenen
familien
der rettungskräfte laufe bereits
leichteren einsatzkräften danken
insbesondere natürlich den kameradinnen
und kameraden der feuerwehr die als
erste vor ort waren und die natürlich
auch die betroffenen persönlich kennen
und deswegen eine sehr sehr schwere
aufgabe heute zu erledigen hatten
bisher fand die polizei keine hinweise
auf einen technischen defekt oder ein
fehlverhalten des fahrers gutachter
sollen den bus aber noch untersuchen
die beiden achtjährigen unfallopfer das
teilte die polizei inzwischen mit
stammen aus dem direkten nachbarort von
berker bei eisenach dort soll es morgen
einen trauergottesdienst geben
in spanien ist die zahl der todesopfer
nach dem heftigen wintersturm gestiegen
jetzt auf mindestens sieben
mehrere menschen werden noch immer
vermisst mit mehr als 100
stundenkilometern war sturm gloria über
die balearen inseln und den osten des
landes gefegt mit eisregen und massivem
wellengang und das sind bilder aus
katalonien dort kilometerweit land unter
jetzt machen wir schnitt in dieser
sendung und kommen zum sport und damit
zu dir christian abt nach down under
drei deutsche tennisprofis in runde drei
bei den open in melbourne nach julia
görges auch angelique kerber und
alexander 12 kerber nach dem 6 3 und 6 2
gegen die australische qualifikantin
priscilla horn trifft nun auf die
italienerin camila giorgi ebenfalls ohne
satzverlust alexander zverev erste regen
mit der roten asche dann die putzkolonne
und dann auch alexander zverev die
formkrise zu beginn des jahres in
melbourne wie weggewischt gegen den
weißrussen gerasimov mit serve und
volley und wichtig der aufschlag ist
stabil im gesamten match kein
doppelfehler
ich weiß dass es dinge gibt die ich
immer noch verbessern muss
es gibt sie nehmen die mit denen ich
noch nicht so zufrieden war
aber gut ich dafür habe ich noch das
nicht gut dass es noch etwas zu
verbessern gibt trotz des glatten 7 zu 6
6 4 und 7 zu 5
als nächstes wartet der spanier fernando
verdasco überraschung durch paul fans
aus berlin bei den eiskunstlauf
europameisterschaften in graz der 27
jährige liegt nach dem stärksten
kurzprogramm seine karriere auf rang
sechs und würde mit einer inflation
unter den top 10 nach der kür einen
zweiten deutschen männer startplatz bei
der nächsten em sichern und gelungener
auftakt für die deutschen biathleten
beim weltcup in pokljuka drei unter den
ersten zehn wobei philipp nawrath als
vierter im einzel über 20 kilometer das
beste resultat seiner noch jungen
laufbahn erzielte so recht ließ er sich
feiern philipp nawrath der nach guter
laufleistung und fehlerfreiem schießen
das podest nur ganz knapp verpasste
dort war wie so oft der franzose martin
fourcade zu finden
fehlerfrei am schießstand aber durch
einen sturz ließ er wichtige sekunden
liegen und musste deshalb dem ebenfalls
makellos schießenden schnell schützen
johannes ten die sp den vortritt lassen
und der norweger siegte mit 11,4
sekunden vorsprung
ein dritter fonds landsmann fabia claude
total ausgepowert so schön danke
christin jetzt noch das ohne um auch
total ausgepowert ohne motor über den
wilden atlantik riesenwellen wind und
dagegen einfach nur die kraft der
muskeln im dezember auf den kanaren ging
es los jetzt haben vier hamburgerinnen
die karibikinsel antigua erreicht in 42
tagen und 46 minuten über den großen
teich kein anderes frauenteam war
schneller
die freude riesig und nach 5068
kilometern auf dem ruderboot auch die
vorfreude auf eine dusche und ein
richtiges bett und wie sie sagen auf
frische früchte die wetterprognose und
zurzeit ist einfach und schwierig
einfach sonne und nebel schwierig wie
viel von beidem wo genau erklärt gleich
alles katja honnefer das heute journal
mit der kollegin marietta slomka um
21.45 morgen gibt es uns wieder punkte
vom gesamten heute 19 uhr team danke für
ihr interesse und in allen ein
angenehmer abend
[Musik]
genau wie meine damen und herren
sonnenschein oder nebel diese frage
beschäftigt uns auch noch in den
nächsten tagen auf diesem satelliten
film sehen sie sehr schön wie sich die
sonne immer besser durchsetzte zb hier
rund um den harz oder auch im sauerland
jetzt danach bildet sich zum teil wieder
neuer je bildungs es gibt doch etwas
dichtere wolken in norddeutschland unter
klarem sternenhimmel sinken die
temperaturen bis minus sieben grad unter
den dichteren wolken bleibt es milder
bei fünf grad und diese dichteren wolken
in norddeutschland die beschäftigungs
morgen darüber tag da kann es auch mal
ein bisschen nieselregen geben weiter
richtung süden kommt die sonne immer
besser zum vorschein strahlendem
sonnenschein besonders morgen nachmittag
zum beispiel hier im erzgebirge in der
oberpfalz auch am alpenrand auf der
schwäbischen alb und im schwarzwald hält
sich der nebel wie hier im donautal
dagegen dichter dann liegen die
höchsttemperaturen morgen kaum bei 0
grad mit sonne gibt es dagegen auf 11
grad sonst liegen die temperaturen
zwischen 3 und 8 grad
am samstag gibt es dann ganz
freundliches wetter für einige von uns
am sonntag könnte ein bisschen regen
fallen hier im südosten und ab montag
ändert sich als dazu morgen mehr schönen
abend